this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to EE 380s computer systems
laboratory colloquium fall 2012 2013 I'm
Andy Freeman the other course organizer
is Dennis Allison I want to thank how
Marie for stepping in the last two weeks
and doing introductions computer
scientists are fond of making grand
pronouncements one of them is Alan Kay's
perspective is worth 80 IQ points and
this has been restated by the open
source community as all bugs are shallow
given enough eyes we have a variation in
the funding now and venture funding
called crowdsourcing and I seem to
remember the same concept in early 60s
or before science fiction got well as
crowdfunding I'm sorry crowdfunding
today's speaker Richard US has taken
this concept and applied it to
real-world phenomena to do
experimentally driven scientific
hypothesis hypothesis generation and it
turns out that by some measures 37,000
game players can outperform a few
hundred experts Wow sort of odd so okay
um just a little bit of background on
myself I'm in the biochemistry
department here at Stanford I actually I
have a courtesy appointment in physics
because my training is completely in
physics infected in my PhD here at
Stanford and but the project i'm gonna
tell you about is neither really neither
of bio chemistry or physics or
electrical engineering or computer
science it's this very bizarre video
game project that i started as a side
project about three years ago and now
it's completely engulfed my lab but in
in a good way and in fact that's why i
was a little bit late today it's because
i was chatting with these video game
players who are very intense and i lost
track of the time so firstly i need to
introduce you to a so tackler molecule
one that i've been obsessed about for
the last ten years is called RNA and to
see information carrying molecule in all
of our living cells it's composed of
four chemical constituents we label them
as AC
gnu and defects in how rnase fold up and
cut and paste themselves have been
traced to a huge numbers of diseases one
example is on childhood spinal muscular
atrophy another example is parkinson's
these are diseases of the brain or of
the of the neural system that have been
traced to problems in how aberrant ways
in which rnase can fold up many actually
all retroviruses including HIV and sours
and polio their genomes and are made
entirely of RNA and there are critical
components of this genome that fold up
into intricate structures and and an
hour necessary for viral infection and
for viral replication so one idea that
many labs around the world are are
tempted by our tantalized by is well
what if we could cure a brain disease or
defeat a virus by manipulating or
disrupt these RNA components and maybe
even better what if we could fight fire
with fire what we could create an RNA
device that itself then acts on the RNAs
in the cell or in the virus and and
disrupts their folds so this is what you
might call the RNA design problem and
that there are many issues in this field
but it's very hard there's there's one
kind of biophysical or even computer
science ii problem that I'm illustrating
here okay and here's a question I'm
drawing here a shape that this RNA
strand can form and what the puzzle is
this you need to give me a sequence of
ACS geez and use to fill in these blanks
so that a's pair with use and seezle
pair of geez okay and that's pretty easy
to do but the hard part is you have to
give me a sequence that does not prefer
to fold up into an alternative shape
that also pairs a phase and use and
season geez okay so that's the RNA
design problem and it seems fairly
simple and in fact there are algorithms
that can solve this through a kind of
Monte Carlo process but the problem in
practice is not solved and I'd like to
illustrate that with a little little
quiz so what I'm showing you here are
two potential solutions to that problem
and I'm going to ask you just to look at
these patterns of
was greens and yellows and reds and
maybe try to guess well what are these
folds up correctly it turns out we now
know one of them doesn't so just look at
it and see could you kind of figure out
some differences between them that would
tell you which ones right now I'm going
to tell you a couple of things while
you're thinking the first is that if i
put these sequences into their there are
dozens of web servers that that will
predict RNA folds for you both of these
sequences will for any server will fold
up perfectly in silico okay so no no
computer algorithm can tell these two
apart they both look perfect teleport ah
what I'm trying to I'm going to show you
in a second that one of these folds up
correctly one of them doesn't when you
actually synthesize it in a test tube I
can see it as yeah so what what is what
is the feature set of features that will
tell me which one miss folds which
unfolds correctly so this is just a
two-dimensional representation move the
molecule folds up in three dimensions
you're exactly right and I've skipped
over a couple of steps here so oh yeah I
want to say that I've only prepared
about there's about 20 minutes worth of
slides so I welcome questions during the
presentation the real RNA folds up into
a three-dimensional structure and
typically by folding back to form double
he'll seize those wz to represent here
in the schematic as as these base pairs
as these pairings okay and the
algorithms that we have for carrying out
RNA folding are simplified and they say
they they don't take into account
three-dimensional path of the RNA they
make use of empirical rules for how
strong these a's and use and seasoned
GSR and how strong some and how good or
bad it is to have certain bulged out
letters and but those are empirical but
they it's actually to a little bit too
hard for us to to model these in three
dimensions that's actually what I mainly
work on my lab not going to talk about
here but here's a question reality is is
there any kind of feature here even at
this 2d level that where you can you can
see a difference so I can quickly point
out that this the sequence on this
design on the left it has more of these
yellow letters these a's at the tips and
in the central bubble-like region
whereas this one over here
the right-hand one is more diverse and
that could be good or that could be bad
you don't know any guesses for who
thinks who thinks this one the left is
the one that fills up correctly just
humor me and raise your hand for one of
them all right so we've got four people
learning for this one and I think
someone on the right okay so the
majority are going for the one of the
right okay those very interesting
because um I've given this to a computer
science audience in the past and they
got it right but I think you guys got it
wrong um the only way we can figure this
out no expert or computer knows which
one if any pulls up correctly so we
synthesize these in my lab and we carry
out a procedure called chemical mapping
I'm not going to go into too much detail
but they basically it basically tells
you you should be banned is a
experimental readout of how reactive one
of these letters is called nucleotides
and the if a letter is reactive those
should correspond to parts of the
structure that are sticking out here and
letters are unreactive should correlate
to the parts that are paired up inside
he'll Oh Sees and i'm coloring those as
yellow and blue blue respectively for
this design on the left the nucleotides
that are supposed to be unpaired are
largely yellow and that's what we want
this is about as good as it gets well
for this design on the right well parts
of it are correct this arm and this arm
have basically the right chemical
mapping pattern whereas in the middle
there are some differences between what
we wanted and so this RNA is more likely
to fold up into structure I've shown
okay it's it's miss folded a bit in the
middle and this is a small tweak but
even a small change like this could be
fundamentally a fundamental flaw in any
kind of new RNA device or therapy now
the twist here would you probably
anticipated is the the origins of these
two designs the one on the right was
designed by an automated algorithm
called new pack which is probably the
most sophisticated method that we have
today is developed by Caltech Caltech
group over the last five years and the
one on the left here the correct design
was created by a video game player named
angry on he called the design type an
and he had no prior expertise he or she
no prior expertise in RNA folding or
design so this is a kind of anecdotal
example of how video game players might
be able to create designs that work that
are experimentally and its following in
a line of a very interesting scientific
discovery projects that have emerged
over the last ten years I'd say the
first big ones of these came out of the
astronomy community NASA click workers
crowdsource the analysis of images of
the moon and this really expanded for
the Zooniverse products like Galaxy Zoo
to encompass cosmological images of
galaxies and and even further objects in
2008 a video game canakkale called
folded I was probably involved in this
that let players optimized
three-dimensional folds of molecules
purely in silico and this made headlines
last year when some players created a
model of a retroviral protease that
actually solved what's called the face
problem for the crystal structure of
that protein and that was a problem that
had eluded expert scientists for ten
years um what the project I'm going to
tell you about today is called echar una
and its really unprecedented in in one
major way okay these unlike the prior
projects which were purely they were
they were crowdsourcing purely in silico
tasks just computational tasks like
optimization or image analysis eternal
is unique in this inclusion of
experimental bio bio science it's unique
and giving players the ability to
control experiments come up with new
hypotheses and test them in the wet lab
okay I'd like to show you how that works
maybe I'll give you a quick demo what
the game looks like just or make a
concrete and the question is do I have
internet connection here
shed
okay I'll come back to it later then I
have a little movie so you can see what
it looks like okay well here's here's
the way it works every week we have a
challenge shape okay and we let players
they have access to this mildly
addictive game like interface to create
sequence designs and then they have
access to all the other players designs
and they vote on which ones they like
best for that week and then we take the
top-ranked designs and then we
synthesize them in my lab again I want
to emphasize this that this is the this
is the crux of the project we actually
synthesize these random sequences coming
from God knows who on the internet in my
lab and then we carry out these chemical
mapping methods and then we return those
results back into the into the game for
players to see the definition the best
here is well it's the experimental data
Oh best me which ones we synthesized
those are ranked by players what does
whatever they consider vest okay what if
they decide to look like a teddy bear
instead I can as long as I get to the
other folks to vote for it okay yeah um
and we'll come back to that more you'll
actually see some 20 very cool bedroom
eww yeah yeah oh yeah i'll show you some
stuff later um the okay so as you can
see here where we're going from
hypothesis to experiments to results
back to the next hypothesis in some
sense this we're trying to hear
crowdsource the entire scientific method
on a video game kind of platform now
it's here you have a target geometry and
you trying to find the sequence as
opposed to sequence and try to find its
forward right Sakura yeah after the
sequence to folding every since
two-dimensional simplification can be
solved in polynomial time but the
backwards problem appears to be NP NP
our problem
but but beyond that in so the fact that
it's kind of difficult and
computationally there is this other
issue where there are features that are
computer algorithms and energy models
are missing and we're hoping that
players can figure those out bye-bye do
an experiment so I'd like to tell you
some of the first results from the
project that emerged last year we
started largeness last January this is
the first target shape that we gave to
players we it has three we called into
grams we called the three helix
articulated shape but in the project be
gaming called it the finger because it
has to duck holes in the fingertip and
for all these shapes we have been as a
baseline we've been synthesizing designs
made by automated computer algorithms
and in addition to getting the
nucleotide or by letter or chemical
mapping data we also summarize those
data into a one numerical score and
that's for simplicity I'm just plotting
those scores here they go from zero to
100 these initial computer designs were
sort of a mixed bag where most of the
player one of most of these designs has
scores around 90 so and hundred is best
ok so the most of these are around 80 to
90 sort of a minuses view pluses and if
you are really bad what's that score
measures the similarity of the chemical
mapping pattern to what we'd expect if
the RNA folded up correctly so it's
basically a correlation score ok well
yeah the shape initially there was
initially they were ad hoc they were
just yeah and you'll see that we tried
to make them have more and more complex
shapes but there's no I mean there's no
canonical series of shapes that anyone
has come up with in the field say oh
this is the progression of harder and
harder shapes you'll see later on if I
remember lol some of the later shapes
were designed by players to explicitly
test their ideas i'll come back to that
but for this first series we just had a
list that we came up with almost
randomly pencil and paper this is how
well the players did for that first on
their first
the first chance to get experimental
data their designs or again also bimodal
like the computer and in fact you can't
really tell there's no difference here
so and again none of these players just
like the computer did none of them
created designs that were close to a
hundred or supposed to perfect close to
perfect but maybe that was expected
because at this point the players hadn't
seen any experimental data yeah okay so
they're doing as well for as bad as the
non Butorac there's also constrained by
the model too I mean it's their only
grading structure which the model says
will fold correctly yeah so yes right so
we decided to impose a criterion that
whatever designs are submitted should
fold up properly given the computational
model right so the computational model
is wrong then well what we're hoping is
that the players would find features on
top that are beyond that either are
robust to errors in the computational
models or they'd find sort of additional
features energetic terms in there that
intuitively compensate for errors in the
model but players different have a big
handicap here that the programs of the
design by people who know a lot and you
gave them a 15 minute intro and some
flashy stuff yeah yeah they're not even
a gun makin a gun to shoot the experts
yeah well no no video games you know
first-person shooter as a human up they
don't even have a pfg yeah and you're
throwing them into that's right for
wolves that's right that's right yeah
yeah yeah yeah here's what happened over
the next few months of the game yeah we
had no idea if this is going to work
that's why I said it's just like a
little side project anyway so what I'm
showing here is the progress over the
next six months over six progressively
more complex shapes and i'll put the
trends the first is if you look at these
gray symbols those are marking the
computational designs and they are
getting worse and worse and worse as
these shapes are getting more elaborate
more complex with more kilo CS and
little junctions and things whereas the
human designs are in colored points and
you can see that they've been basically
monotonically increasing over the span
of the game so that by these last few
designs the first round designs by the
players their median score exceeds the
best score created by the computers and
typically at least one out of there in
this case eight or so designs is in
signature from perfect given our heart
experimental assay okay so that's that's
what happened now the question is how do
they do it and what we are really
excited by was that the players were
making forum posts and talking and chat
but they were trying to formalize the
rules that they were using to create the
designs for the next round and yeah well
it's better than so yeah I'll going
explain so 100 would be perfect the
experiment the error like we repeat the
measurements done on any of these
designs is the mean unsigned errors
about four four percent so if you're
above 96 that that means within our
experimental area as close as we can
tell from to perfect now for some of
these we've actually carry out further
experimental methods that my lab has
developed that are much more information
rich and much better falsifying these
players I'm centers that the Green Line
is not the perfect what is that this is
this is the range where is its suitable
imperfect given this essay yeah yeah so
they may be they may well be perfect we
just can't tell okay so make sense we
can't falsify those designs everything
blowed line we can falsify is having a
problem so how are they doing it and
I'll give you an example this is a rule
that was posted on the forums by a
player named you like this and he said
all GC pairs in the multi lube junctions
have to turn from the same direction GC
through these red green pairings and he
said you have to have them going from
green to red and green to red clockwise
around these loops in the game
representation there's one exception
which is the green red pair that's
absolutely neck can be gone either
direction okay so if this sounds weird
to you it it sounded weird for me as
well there's no concept of turning in
the same direction in the are
a folding literature there's no this
idea of a neck to a design which is this
longest range pairing set of pairings in
the RNA that hadn't been identified as
an important feature in prior work those
bonds saw a double bonds of triple bonds
and they can sense direction again so
the market mark yourself is kyra yeah so
in this is very important there's no so
physically this is a reasonable rule but
the to your computer rules have chiral
rules they do the energetic in principle
their entire families that are in the in
silico models they distinguish between
they distinguish between these those
clips of whether the g's on this side or
this side also the double double bonds
are sensitive to charge the longer
distance if you wish between a parent
that has it topologically but at what
that presumably has an impact with again
with prior experimental measurements on
model Hilo sees there doesn't seem to be
in effect beyond about the nearest
neighbors but again that could be that
could be because of the limited data set
high electrons going up to 60 code
elements so they can pick up so they
they can't right and there's also just
coolin because that's not just neighbor
there's also clue in principle columbic
interactions it's very simple basic so
physics has quite a bit more that you're
not having in that it does but i should
say again i won't emphasize that in the
models that are there in silico in
principle they include these Carl
effects and principle they can include
these energetic effects but the ones we
have are based on experiments carried
out by really great people like Doug
Turner and colleagues over 20 years or
so and they've come up with these models
that seem to fit the data they don't
actually include beyond nearest neighbor
effects that's partly because they don't
have enough data to figure out what
those are and also it's impossible to
simulate it's been difficult to simulate
the energetics of these systems so what
we were hoping for with this project is
that the players would into it that
there may be as you said non nearest
neighbor rules that are in the
computational models more rules about
the chirality of ecgs that aren't in the
actually there are rules for the cgi
realities but only within he'll seize
because no one's cared enough
measurement for these more complex mode
to actually come up with a micro it's
called the circulated all possess
functionality yeah it has Michelle
exactly right but it's again it's hard
to design it's bad afterwards I don't
know I think I think he's a really
important point yeah so I think I see
things the rules that players have come
up with when you want to read them in
retrospect they seem they're reasonable
once I understand what their turf syntax
means there's a whole jogging that's
emerged in the community and they've
written lexicons to explain to you what
a neck is and what turning is but once I
initial that was then exactly this is in
principle physically reasonable but it's
okay so but is it is it right okay so i
can say that here that you either is the
top player in the project he's had the
most designs synthesized and the most
designs that i've had near
indistinguishable scores so this may
have predictive power but we wanted to
really really rigorously test this so
starting at the end of last year we
created an explicit game within a game
which we call the strategy market where
we're order players for proposing these
kinds of rules in short sort of 150
words snippets in English that we then
coated up into into Python snippets and
where we which would assign a score
based on the input description that you
saw in the previous slide and then we
just use basic you know least angles
regression ER to to find a linear
combination of these scores at best
explain the previous the data that we
had to that point and then we call it up
a really simple montecarlo algorithm we
called eternal bot which tries to
optimize this layer derived score okay
so that we thought that would be a nice
rigorous and unbiased way to test these
ideas so let me show you how that worked
on here's a completely new shape
actually this is a shape that was to
answer previous question was proposed by
a player as being probably hard for
prior algorithm so the shapes i'm going
to show you now how i should all player
post so we took these are actually two
previous design algorithms their scores
plotted and these are the designs from
some humans for this shape and as i was
showing you before again
better than the computers how did this
newly turn a bot design algorithm to
will actually surround it it bridges the
gap between the previous algorithms and
these designs we've now carried out
these tests on eight different shapes
and in the majority of the cases the
eternal odd designs bridges the gap
between the computers in the humans
there's still a couple cases where
that's not the case then we hypothesize
that as we get more and more features
will be able to completely close that
gap but I think that's remarkable here
that is that this eternal odd algorithm
which is the distillation of in this
case hundreds or thousands of people's
ideas it is the best algorithm that we
have for designing RNA secondary
structure how many how many people's
lives nobody blares there's now over
50,000 players so last year there was
sort of about 30,000 players was the
average number not all of them that
those are people who registered about a
tenth of those people play enough that
they earned the privilege of submitting
solutions that we could synthesize okay
and I would say within that number about
100 people are really into it like
they're making forum posts and coming up
with strategies etc yes how do you
recruit them uh-oh how do we recruit
them yeah um word of mouth hi yeah okay
so you have no idea there they can be
like people just randomly reading like
tech blogs or they could be like med
students they could just yeah we started
we don't really have a sense of there's
something she's doing this tweet we
started with when we're doing beta
testing before the official reviews we
put some posts up on gaming blogs like
there's the game foal org by Jane
McGonigal and we also put up a post on
the folded games blog so we got some
people there some of whom we knew from
knew from before like my mic OPI on this
daydream Troy he wrote the folded video
game so he knew these folks but
interestingly most of them they were
helpful in the beta testing but they
left we found a really different
community of players for this game than
what we saw unfolded there this
community is much less driven by
competition
and when they've been interviewed by
folks in the press the first thing they
tell you is not how many points they won
or where their ranking is in the game
they tell you how many designs they've
had synthesized and the thing that
excites them the most is to see the
experimental data for the designs that
they they design and so it's remarkably
similar to what I think drives me in
science which is like here's my
apophysis is it right or wrong I want to
see the experiment eight I want the
answer and I'm actually also quite happy
if it's wrong and there's a very
interesting that there's a large group
of people none of whom have academic
science backgrounds as far as I can tell
from chatting who have this hook at the
same rush so yeah I it's it and they
don't it's fruit I just was chatting
with them and saying how we're going to
reward in this next part of the game how
are we going to set up rewards and stuff
and they're like god screw the rewards
it doesn't matter just get it running
world will play of synthesizing is
studying work i sent the census is the
reward yeah that's what I they know
something that nobody else in the world
knows yeah that's an incredible rush
yeah yeah a little cool offers let's
come back to that yeah yeah all right so
be um here's the thing so the games been
progressing really well but the
hypotheses go well beyond what I
described in the strategy market there
are really just beautiful ideas coming
up there here's what is one player l
Rafi who says I like the idea of shapes
and constraints that help us discover
where the model does not work so she he
or she really wants to create designs
that will actually fail in the lab okay
here's an example of a challenge that
they set up where it took the existing
lab puzzles that can we make these
designs just with two of the four
letters just A's and use em here's
another example players they're creating
shapes we have an interface where you
can create your own puzzles in the game
and this is a like a snowflake type
shape that actually it's impossible for
any prior design algorithm to to create
a sequence that folds up into the shade
even just computationally in silico but
like in this case nine other players
have found solutions for it and then
getting at the teddy bear question some
folks have been you know creating
personal expressions so this came out
after Steve Jobs died last year player
put up a design and I would love to know
and all the players would love to know
whether these sequences folded up in the
test tube in the way that they've been
designed here but there's an issue this
is the what I call the original sin of
the project we actually haven't been
able to synthesize these designs so the
issue that we have is we don't now have
over 50,000 registered players kind of
like what I was saying a little over
four thousand of these folks have played
enough to submit lab designed and we get
for each each cycle of synthesis we get
about a thousand candidates now but
we're only able to synthesize about
eight a week I have a have a pretty
small lab to start my lab and at least
the protocol that we were using only
because it has this kind of a throughput
so we were getting a lot of feedback
like oh you know you should you should
have a class system where there are some
expert players you should always let
them have designs and let the other
people not have them or we were going to
implement like a peer review where all
the designs so there's a complaint that
the eight signs I got made everywhere by
the most popular people and not by the
smartest people and some folks are
saying we should have a peer review
system where every design every one of
these thousand designs has to be vetted
by four or five other people before they
get considered and then I realize you
know we're trying that's a super hard
problem you know you have limited
resources and a lot of people it's
really you know it's a problem of
political science you know how marks
couldn't solve it how are we going to
solve it but then I realize we can solve
it so we can we live in the Bay Area and
so in some of us are technically
utopians there should be a technological
solution to the problem and indeed there
is you've probably heard another talks
in the series about the revolution
that's under going on in biology with
the advent of really cheap nucleic acid
synthesis DNA and RNA
thesis and DNA and RNA sequencing and it
turns out that we've devised an
experimental pipeline where we can take
thousands actually even millions of
designs and upload them to a website the
agilent website actually and they send
they'll send us back in the mail glass
slide is printed which one of those
designs on the time scale of a few weeks
and then we can transcribe the rnase
from these chip bound dnas and then the
chemical mapping protocol I mentioned
earlier it turns out there's a way to
read this out using these so-called
next-generation sequencing technologies
and so this is going to let us
synthesize and get the structural data
on 30,000 or 40,000 sequences /
synthesis cycle okay so we should be
able to take anything that's typed into
the video game and instantiate it in
reality and tell you what the answer is
so it's it's what i'm calling like cloud
computation looks like but it's cloud
biochemistry you literally couldn't be
typing stuff into your laptop and then
you will get back an answer for what it
did in a test tube a few days later um
so with this kind of throughput though
it would really you'd be almost a waste
to just have these one shape a week you
know and give me thirty thousand
sequences that fold into the shape since
we have so many beautiful hypotheses
coming and I said there's a thousand
designs coming in we only make eight
there's probably hundreds of other ideas
that are not related to the lab
challenges there's snowflakes order
those apple shapes um what we'd like to
do instead is to reward folks for what
they're already doing they're coming
together and discussing very complex
hypotheses we could never think of and
we're going to reward them for designing
experiments that test those hypotheses
and we'll run those as synthesis slots
in our new biochemical cloud um and then
we'll reward them for writing little
micro papers where with starting with
hypotheses test data conclusion most of
these fields will already be populated
right because we
reward them for coming up with
hypotheses in the experiment and these
data will be coming directly out of our
pipeline so all they have to do is fill
in a conclusion or what they learn and
you've got something like a little chunk
of scientific knowledge and then we'll
be taking the top rank of these papers
and helping edit them for purification
now i want to emphasize something here
these papers are little micro papers
they're not going to cure cancer okay
there are little tidbits of knowledge
but on how to design a pseudo nod or a
five-way junction out of RNA but they
are they are two bits of scientific
knowledge they will have experimental
data that falsify or validate but what
the folks are presenting and when an
expert researcher at MIT really is
trying to cure cancer in two years and a
co I you know I really need to make this
RNA into a pseudo not to deliver it to
tumor cells well now if they type that
into PubMed are the standard database of
the biomedical literature they'll get
nothing on pseudoknot design but in a
couple of years we think that they'll
types i didn't they'll get two or three
papers by players showing you here's how
you do it and here's how you don't do it
we just played with this a year ago and
i think that's going to be very powerful
in fact you did a back-of-the-envelope
calculation if if this we can get this
pipeline working the publication
pipeline working well the eternal
project will be creating experimentally
validated knowledge at a rate that's one
to two orders of magnitude greater than
all current labs who work on RNA folding
and design so that's the hope i think
it's going to happen because especially
cuz earlier this year I asked folks well
what if you were able to design anything
you wanted just end this just send us
the sequences and some names for those
sequences and we got a list of we cut it
off at a thousand sequences and here's
here's that initial list and but
completely floored me is that some
things on this list there's one label
the elder te pre-mrna kink turn I
actually know what that is that is a
piece of RNA from ourselves that I
happen to be interested in but it's
probably probably five other labs in the
world know what this isn't care about it
but somehow a player of the project had
been doing a database search and said I
really want to make this and see what it
looks like
eterna and they typed it in and that's
when I realized that actually a
substantial amount of number of the
problems in my lab could also be mapped
to this platform and so this is no
longer really a side project it's really
something that amplifies my lab and in
addition brings me into contact with
hundreds of colleagues who I who are
probably just as smart or smarter than
the folks in my lab um let me just
quickly summarize here we start you turn
a couple of years ago and hope to
crowdsource a scientific method and over
the last year we've started to see that
non-expert players motivated by the
thrill of synthesis are now
outperforming computers at the problem
of designing RNA secondary structures
and we're hoping over the next year to
harness that knowledge not just in terms
of one big paper a year but in terms of
the hopefully dozens of micro papers
written by the players themselves and I
want to welcome if any of you are
interested in the Blackwell engineering
or or CS communities the next steps in
the project we're trying to design basic
elements that would be useful for RNA
computers and this goes back to creating
devices to deliver gene therapy or to
help diagnose cells that are going
cancerous or infected by viruses you
would be ideal to have rnase that are
act as logical elements that changes our
structure in response to what other
rnase are in a Cell what the languages
of that kind of RNA computer what the
fundamental components are it's not yet
clear but we have this really wonderful
platform for creating those devices
whatever we think they are and in
addition to the sort of nano engineering
type of aspect we could use help on the
machine learning for creating automated
algorithms from what folks are
submitting as well so if your interests
in any of that please come in and talk
to me so that's all I have I do want to
thank my colleagues in the project I
cope Mike OPI is Adrienne Troy who is a
professor at Carnegie Mellon he's
actually here in the Bay Area now as at
Google X for at least a year or two ji
hyun lee is his star graduate student
who did all the coding for the project
then n and Daniel and I took most of the
data that I showed you for the project
and then of course I like to thank all
the players who have contributed the
actual designs for the for the project
and thanks to you for your attention one
of those numbers beneath the players
names that's how many um nucleotides
they have that's the in-game currency
yeah which they don't care about yeah so
most of your pictures had a big circle
over on the right mmm what's the
significance of that you mean the shapes
that we're trying to make yeah um yeah
yeah most of them do all over here oh
it's right so in this two-dimensional
representation where this is not the
actual path of that RNA and in three
dimensions or two dimensions it's just a
kind of hard to factor though this
common weight is to schema ties but
those strands are suppose parts of the
RNA are supposed to be unpaired now they
all have that because we ask folks to
design the RNA so they begin with the
letters GG and a few other nucleotides
and they end in the specific sequence
because it makes our experiments easier
for example the I didn't like I'm having
to go into details but you'll probably
get bored to carry out the chemical
mapping we reverse transcribe the RNAs
and that requires having a constant
sequence at the end that we can prime 1
2 so we ask players to take that into
account because that's what we're gonna
make this is really a loop or just that
writing that for convenience but secure
ways right yeah no it's not it's not
really a circle in the test tube it's
just drawn like that if the nucleotide
should be unpaired they shouldn't be
contacting anything else and when when
we do get data on those regions they do
appear to be unpaired so those ants can
go anywhere they don't have preferred
locations sort of like saying the two
ends a preferred location right no no no
that's not the case not sound okay sir
so thanks for asking a question yes so
so key thing else it brush yeah it's not
yeah the way the other way you should
two drivers coming off with straight
lines or draw them the squiggles their
different ways to draw this is just a
compact waited for the for the
presentation look see young turnaround
cost basically if you're doing a
thousand sequel to the time what's the
economics of the whole thing oh yeah
well let's think so the the cost of
these the synthesis and the cost of the
sequencing are dropping faster than
Moore's law and they have been for about
the last I'd say five years so that for
doing for doing 30,000 of these at a
time the cost worth it this is so great
if ice if I upload that you know text
file with a thousand or 40,000 sequences
the cost for that microarrays $500 so it
costs less than the scent I think point
one cents per DNA those nothing right so
that scales beautifully and then the
cost of sequencing are in that range as
well so per that's that's kind of why I
called the cloud biochemistry approach
these many of the players wanted to they
got so obsessed with getting their stuff
synthesized they wanted to carry out
these experiments in the garage for
their backyard and so we went through
all the costs and i said here's what you
have to be you'd have to buy and to
build up your own lab in your backyard
and it just ended up being very
expensive if you're only making a few at
a time but with this economy of scale
with the sequencing and synthesis by
doing one extreme in my lab I can do
experiments for 100 or 1,000 people had
negligible cost per person or per
experiment use these shapes are useful
has anybody come to you and say hey can
you try our shapes instead of you know
those shale example yes yes so what we
haven't we haven't put them up yet the
the the really useful so we started here
with trying to predict a certain problem
of preceding shapes but the what
everyone wants to do is to predict to
create sequences that change their shape
when they see another in a molecule
looks for example you'll put these into
yeast cells or bacterial cells and they
want the back him to swim towards a
herbicide and eat it up when it sees
that herbicide small molecule and folks
have done this and so that required
designing the RNA that changes his
confirmation when it binds that when it
sees that small molecule and so there
and so these are switches the ones that
have been made that have worked in the
laboratory over the last few years have
required a huge amount of trial and
error for very clever kinds of in vitro
or in vivo selections okay what we're
trying to do is to find a way to do that
without trial and error so right now if
you play eternal if you play our lab
challenges the challenges actually are
these switch puzzles where we give you
two shape two shapes and you have to
make the RNA fold into one shape one but
when it sees the small molecule fold
into shape too and then we're actually
mapping their structure in those two
conditions as well so that's been really
interesting and turns out that's a
problem that is a even harder than even
computationally it's an unsolved problem
to do that multi-state design yeah what
tools that the players actually use on
their on the client side and what would
be even better or what you envision as
enhancing their ability yeah just that
that's what we're talking about in this
chat the players we give them access to
these folding algorithms we give them
access to algorithms that estimate how
not just the probability of seeing their
structure but the probabilities of
seeing other misc folder structures that
you can go swim yes the partition
function for the the folding can be
estimated and that's given to players in
silico and they can visualize it in a
certain way the players themselves have
often made use of other servers that are
available for RNA design or for folding
do does a strange world work you just
say RNA servers that are available yeah
so sorry their servers for computational
RNA structure prediction and design
there's dozens and we don't you know we
can't impose any restrictions on what
people use so there are fascinating
posts where some player has gone through
every design that was submitted for a
lab puzzle and they've run it through
this other server
and then they post what they would what
they got another server is there is
there some extra meaning we can get so
that's what folks have now I think the
really important next step for the game
is in terms of creating tools is to
include and the players of the Manning
list they want their own scripting
interface and be ability to create their
own tools and to share them and that's
been very important for the folded
project for the protein 3d folding
project it's going to be I think
transformed of here as well yeah it was
example of warmed rules I'm gonna came
up how many rules people have come up um
for that for the studies for this study
that I showed you for the sea turnabout
algorithm we took the we had about 40
rules when we sort of froze the
algorithm I think now the number of
strategies there's about there's
probably 100 to 200 if not more I
haven't checked but because we have
volunteered to code everything up in the
snippets we haven't mailed to keep up
with the number of strategies coming out
that's also why we want to create these
in-game scripting languages so that the
players can scales much better if the
players themselves are scripting their
own ideas your analyze the rules could
that be kind of like making a much
smaller set thanks yes I so I didn't
mention this we've done for the aterna
wat algorithm we actually made made
three versions one version we did
largely Stangler regression analysis we
picked and it ended up being seeming
like the top five rules you could find
apps wife subset that that accounted for
most of the variation data so we created
an internal algum just using those five
we also did a regression really simple
regression sort of an a least-squares
regression and then we used all 40 rooms
and we had no clue which or if either
would be good right and we thought well
if all 40 of the rules were important
and that that algorithm did better than
we'd have to say oh it's really the
collective intuition of all these folks
but we secretly wanted the top five
rules to be
because that's simpler and easier to
write no paper but we ran we created
sizing both of them I'm showing here
that the green symbols here came from
the sparse set as far as one and for
simplicity I didn't show the other one
but it is it's almost exactly the same
performance yeah why would Leigh square
speed right metric if you touch have a
bunch of programs whatever you don't ok
a program i got use these squares matrix
no no sorry it was least squares but
regular rised with you know like a no
like that so that the cove by the sum of
the coefficient squared so still that's
look I don't know the kind of it's
totally a solely arbitration programming
or basis yeah it's totally arbitrate you
you can use an l1 or the view last no
style analysis there's lost nation
that's what I'm saying especially when
the experimental throughput goes gets
much higher you'll be great to have test
dozens of automated algorithms that use
whatever your favorite most
sophisticated machine learning algorithm
and we can test them all we can yeah
that's going to be fine this whole
premise sounded like it was you were
basically assuming that the structure
you get is only a function of the actual
sequence right couldn't it also be a
function of processing conditions and
things like yeah that's a that's a good
point for all of the cases i showed you
we've actually carried out measurements
in two different solution conditions
that are often used in RNA biophysics
and for almost all of them that the data
and the two conditions match up um so
there are a few exceptions and i haven't
talked about them here but those might
be really interesting but yeah so the
solution conditions but in principle do
matter this wouldn't look at natick
holding
Google that it turns out there aren't
very many good experimental tools for
monitoring RNA folding lols being
transcribed or RNA folding has asbestos
folded that's another big area in my lab
that might the real science that we do
maybe that we gave a what fine
build programs yeah yeah yeah so I
understand but not too many of them have
programming expertise is kind of
interesting I just I just actually this
quick survey of folks who I was chatting
with and probably out of the 20 people
who I was talking to maybe two of them
have programming experience so if you
impose that constraint restraint well
you have to do what gently you have to
basically one of the other soonerlater
you have to get out the program story
hmm so after you get back this big pile
of things that are so cheap what do you
do with them we we synthesize them and
then we carry out this chemical mapping
procedure wait how much is that gonna
cost or how much negativity that doesn't
take very long it takes some about one
day of us doing stuff and then one day
of sequence were time the cost is right
now about a thousand bucks and is
dropping precipitously the reason that
these the cost of the stuff is dropping
so precipitously is because of the
economic demand from whole genome
sequencing the idea that if you walk
into your doctor's office with your
genome they can create a personalized
therapeutic for you you know oh that you
have or they can sequence your your
genome and your cancer genome if you
have a two of us they owe that to like
these five mutations I know right
exactly the right drug to go for it so
there's an it there's a tremendous
economic demand for these technologies
and we are just writing one to come to
help this one let's debate believe that
yeah yeah weed out the bed expensive
customers yeah I don't want to talk well
just charged that the expected cost
okay now you get the right answer
insurance companies make can make money
on high-risk patient high-risk people as
long as the charts incredibly if you
consider that actually being a big piece
of it and you two people see they can
match real evening you're saying should
we send them samples in the mail of the
new Quaker of the molecules yeah just
the mapping of the whole via a pieces of
the it is sucky and solve all this
correctly no that's a good there's no
that's that's that's something I mean
yeah that's why I'm saying about having
this interface with the real science in
my lab we're collecting those kinds of
data on viral genomes or parts of the
rnase in ourselves and yeah I think in
the next year or two will just post that
online and let people look at it but
then it might even be silly though to do
that because the players themselves will
be probably more interested in their own
projects right they're gonna have the
power to Oh try to get as I'm different
yeah this is converging somewhere not
clear what nature would accomplish oh ah
oh you're saying just what what do
national rnase look like this happen
departed correctly oh yeah yeah yeah so
right yeah one thing I didn't mention is
that for scoring these designs and so
forth we we have benchmarks based on
natural orange eyes that's silicon
shapes that have been crystallized their
structures have been solved through
arduous efforts and that's actually
again that's what like what I just made
the red butter in my lab so that's how
that's why we developed these methods
and made them reasonably fast and
efficient but we haven't made that those
data available easily available to the
players within the game they have they
have they actually sometimes a read
papers in my lap so they they they they
know what the data is but how she put
boosting your citation score or your she
read your score like people read a
reader score yeah yeah what's that then
I'm sorry fmn is called flavanol thing
fmn is flavored mononucleotide it's a
a molecule that's present in all of our
cells all living cells it acts as a
redox cofactor meaning it's elektra it's
an electron donor or acceptor in many
chemical and many enzymatic reactions
and it's a it's just a favorite
metabolite or small molecule that
biochemist play with there's a RNA
sequence that's known that specifically
binds fmn and one thing this is this is
more for the biochemistry aficionados
over there probably none in this room
but we have challenges where this they
in the harbor one of these fmn binding
sequences and then we check not only
does the RNA have the right chemical
mapping pattern with the acids I told me
before we can check and see whether they
actually bind up the flame on hookah 10
model of molecule in other words is this
RNA acting is this sequence acting
folding up so correctly that it
scaffolds this shape and it turns out by
measuring the affinities fmn if the fmn
is 100 fold worse than you then expected
it tells you that the correct structure
was present only one percent of the time
is a like stat mech relationship between
the two so it was that was actually is
an orthogonal way to test the accuracy
of these designs where again the players
somehow are doing better than the
computers you're looking at the sort of
the minimum energy design really because
it could be all sorts of secondary
designs of it this a little bit higher
you mean folds oh yeah well in the test
tube we're looking at everything what
they look like that restaurants on
average of all the different we are
essential folds we are in the test who
we are and then within the game what we
present to the players for their
sequence is the minimum energy fold but
they can click on the button and they'll
get information on also the suboptimal
folds and many players use that
information
I guess on the Internet no one knows if
you're a dog or a RNA designer back sort
of cool okay yeah I'm good and now the
cool stuff happens after the camera goes
off okay
you